okay today I'm going to talk to you
about wave calculations now there's two
different types of wave calculation we
need to be able to do now in the in the
revision guide you might see the
equation one of the equations given that
looks like this now I don't actually
like this one here because it's exactly
the same as equation we already know how
to use which is this one here speed
equals distance over time so we're going
to use this one here remember S stands
for speed which is measured in meters
per second D is distance which is
measured in meters and T stands for time
which is measured in seconds so we're
just going to stick to this equation
that we probably know quite well so
classic example might be let's imagine
this wave here this wave here we're told
is traveling at 100 meters per second
and it is travelling for five seconds so
we might be asked how far has this
traveled in that time so remember we're
if we've got our velocity we've got a
soil our speed right here we've got our
time so we're looking for distance so if
we cover up distance we know it's your
speed times time which is five or so 100
times five which is a hundred meters so
that's the first type of equation we
need to do for waves and it's just to do
with speed distance and time waves you
should be okay with from other topics so
the other equation triangle that we
might have looked at is relationship
between frequency velocity and wave
length so if we remember frequency means
how many waves pass a point in one
second and that is measured in Hertz V
in this triangle stands for wave
velocity so that's just how fast is the
wave going and me it's per second and
finally this one here is wave length so
that symbol is actually lambda but it's
just it kind of just symbolizes or
stands for wavelength which is measured
in meters so let's you
another example here so let's say one
two three four five six one two three
four five six so let's say I've had six
waves so if I'm looking at this let's
imagine this is in one second how many
waves have passed so this is how many
waves are passed in one second I know
this must have a frequency of six Hertz
so let's imagine that this wave was
traveling at 60 meters per second that's
my velocity I might be asked to
calculate the wavelength so this is not
drawn to scale might be asked to find
the wavelength in order to find the
wavelength what I need to do is cover up
my wavelength I need to do velocity
divided by frequency so that is 60
divided by six which equals ten and
always remember to put the unit's if I
found the wavelength its measured in
meters so that's how to do the very
basics of wave calculations we're either
going to be looking at something
involving the speed distance and time of
the waves or the frequency the velocity
and the wavelength of the waves so
remember guys the wavelength is a
distance between two either two crests
or two troughs of a wave the velocity
just means how fast is the way of
traveling in a particular direction and
the frequency is how many waves pass one
point in one second and all the units
are given here for you I hope it's been
helpful thank you